[Music]
thank you
and welcome to this very special edition
of The Sky News Daily podcast in fact we
have five special editions for you we'll
be taking a look back at the big stories
from 2022 and how they might affect us
all in 2023. we will be running the
gamut from the royal family politics
economics the war in Ukraine today
though as you might just be able to tell
if you're watching us we will be
focusing on Science and Technology with
of course our Science and Technology
editor Tom Clark lovely to have you on
the daily again Tom thanks for having me
um it's been a year hasn't it indeed yes
and it's in fact it's been quite a hot
year that's right let's start with that
Shelby because I remember temperatures
in the middle of the summer and it's
sort of distance away from it now over
40 degrees
a perfect place to start that's exactly
what I was reflecting on when we
discussed addressing the climate issue
19th of July we passed 40 degrees
centigrade in the UK a temperature that
people speculated we might see with
climate change it seems such a long way
off when discussions like that we're
having but there there we saw it I
remember I was on the hunt for where the
hottest place might be we were driving
around in London I was on a rooftop in
Wembley baking in that heat thinking
about how we were going to handle the
question of relating this temperature
change to Global averages and what that
meant about the climate science what it
meant for the UK and as I looked out
across the London Skyline it was on fire
there were fires springing out across
London and I suddenly thought this does
change things you know it was it went
from being that kind of slow burn
climate story been taking forever to
suddenly an emergency and obviously
fires happened but we saw this almost
instantaneous response of the
environment to that situation and we
suddenly found we were interviewing
firefights that evening about what these
new temperature records might mean you
know it was a remarkable day was this
then was 2022 the year that that Britain
really kind of walk up to the reality of
climate change
I wonder if something changed you know
we we've been talking I mean I've been
talking about my entire career
and it's incremental it's a slow burn
and we have cold years and warm years
and it's the it's the it's the signal
behind the noise when it comes to
climate change but all of a sudden yeah
we had this front and center and we
really felt it and that I think did make
a difference and it happened obviously
after the war in Ukraine had begun and
we were starting to be very aware that
our relationship with the fossil fuel
fossil fuels that drive our economy is
going to have to change and that has a
certain resonance to the whole climate
debate and you know I think it was a
year I I think we'll look back on this
year as a as a pivot point in our
Ambitions and our
um hopes to do something about the
climate change I mean it is difficult
isn't it to indulge in kind of climate
change denialism when you are when you
are living through it but I mean brass
tacks here are we absolutely certain
that what we saw this summer was a
consequence of man's actions and not
just an aberration a one-off
you can never say absolutely we have
heat waves the clamp the clock the
climate is a is a random system driven
by these events so we will have cold
temperatures we may even have future
cold temperature records and I'm sure
the you know the the swivelide climate
denying loonies will jump from the
woodwork and say ah you got it wrong as
they always do but the truth of the
matter is you look at the data the
reason we had a record in July was
because the average global temperature
has gone up by just over a degree
um in the last uh 50 years 100 years and
that means every time we have a heat
wave it'll be that little bit hotter and
those records will come you cannot ever
hand on heart say that particular event
was caused by climate change but the
pattern we're seeing in our temperatures
are undeniably driven by that presumably
this was the year then that the world
was galvanized into action and that we
got all of our world's leaders coming
together and and sorting this problem or
maybe maybe not no and that that's the
interesting the the flip side to this
story it was a year in which we saw the
much hope for coming together of leaders
to discuss the global climate problem
this time in Egypt cop 27 it's called
that U.N climate talks and I think it's
fair to say it was it was very
disappointing in its broader outcomes
some achievements were made there were
some sort of bright spots but largely it
barely built on what was agreed in
Glasgow the year before when there was
some hope we were sort of getting
somewhere I think the feeling coming
away from that was one of disappointment
and of course it's largely I think
because people's attention is focused
elsewhere right now when it's
essentially when it comes to our global
leaders well let's talk then about the
kind of the knock-on effects from the
Ukraine war as you see we had 40 degree
temperatures in July we're expecting
we're like No And from coming into the
office today that temperatures are
significantly less than that now but we
are in the middle of a cost of living
crisis we are in a situation where fund
mentally people cannot afford to heat
their homes something's gone badly wrong
it has and if anything illustrates the
problem that we have and over Reliance
on fossil fuels and over Reliance on
poorly constructive poor interesting
interest in today's times it's this is
an overalliance and fossil fuels or is
it an over-reliance in fossil fuels from
Russia I wouldn't say that actually if
you look at where our fossil fuels come
from by and large we weren't that
dependent on Russia at all what I think
it's Illustrated is our over Alliance on
a global trade in fossil fuels which is
extremely sensitive to things like
conflict in one part of the world drives
up prices in Europe drives up the price
globally and we all suffer and I think
that's been Illustrated it's been played
fairly well although not brilliantly by
Vladimir Putin exploiting that that very
fact and it sort of thrown that into
very very sharp relief
and we are stuck and I think it's
Illustrated how despite all of our
investment and it yeah we'll come on to
talk about the positives in a second but
all their investment in Renewables and
things like that
still 70 of our energy needs so this is
heating our homes and cooking our food
and running our cars still comes from
fossil fuels we are still
hugely reliant on fossil fuels for our
everyday lives but we are changing
things aren't we we have had
announcements on nuclear we thought
there was perhaps going to be an
announcement on kind of onshore wind in
England because of course you can do it
in in other parts of the UK I mean do
you get the feeling that domestically
our political leaders have have got an
approach in mind that they have a
solution to this long term I think they
do now I think it's they can't ignore it
anymore and I think that's one of the
problems we've had particularly in
Britain we relying on really cheap North
Sea gas for a long time we don't have
very harsh Summers we don't have very
cold Winters we could basically just get
away with doing nothing for too long I
think if you want to look for positives
in the Ukraine crisis and I know there
are very very very few one thing that
you could argue yes it's distracted us
from that Noble goal of agreeing on how
to cut emissions but it probably is
going to speed our action to actually
doing something about it uh in in
certainly in Europe and probably in the
US as well where are we in doing in
terms of us being a leader in in Green
Technology it's been a mantor for a
number of politicians how true is it we
have taught a very good talk and I think
we have not we have not done
particularly well you well sorry I
that's unfair we've done particularly
well on Electrify on Greening our
electricity Supply so yeah we've got a
lot of offshore wind we've we've done
really well on that we've we've actually
one of the first to pass legislation to
make it required to ruin ourselves so we
have been leaders but we dragged our
feet in other areas certainly in in how
we are Reliance on gas we dragged our
feet on how we insulate homes but what
we've seen come out of this with the
government's response to the energy
crisis are some significant moves you
know we are now seriously putting our
weight behind nuclear power which is
something that's been long overdue if
unless you're ideologically opposed to
nuclear it's a very very good solution
to the energy crisis we find ourselves
in we are now talking seriously about
addressing the really important issue
for fuel poverty but also of the climate
of making our homes better suited to
cleaner forms of energy and insulating
our homes and making them warmer and
cheaper and healthier for people to live
in if you've watched a minute of Sky
News over the past 12 months you will
undoubtedly have seen at some point the
demonstrations that have been taking
place a variety of groups Extinction
Rebellion just stop oil insulate Britain
to to what extent do you think that
their direct action has had an effect on
the policy making
do you know what I've been mulling this
over because if I was sitting in my car
on the M25 trying to get grid across the
Dartford Bridge
I don't think I'd have quite the same
sympathy for their cause I don't know if
I've got we've got the bleep button
standing by to the extent that would be
required if I had been driving and of
course I feel for anybody who's in that
situation and you think about some of
the emergencies and small life crises
that must have been impacted by that but
if you also step back and you think
really dispassionally about the threats
that climate poses to us and also the
threat that things like our overalliance
on fossil fuels means for people's lives
in the UK we are in a bit of an
emergency here we've been saying it for
a long time and I can also really
sympathize for those who have had enough
and they want to see action well let's
see what happens in in 2023 for now
though let's turn our attention to Big
Tech and I suppose it's probably
slightly smaller Tech than it was this
time last year it's an astonishing if
you think about it these were the
companies who for for a decade or more
had just been on the up and up and up
and are growing and growing and growing
a headline caught my eye the other day
this was after the quarter Q3 results
came out for the five big companies big
Tech I'm just remember who they are
Apple alphabet the parent company of
Google Microsoft
um on Amazon their Collective value
shrank by 3.7 trillion dollars sorry
yeah
it's larger than the GDP of small
countries you know a huge amount of
value White Off Their stock we saw a big
slide in big Tech why right exactly with
all these things it's multiple reasons
but the pandemic had a lot to do with it
a lot of them expanded on the back of us
being shut at home buying more
um stuff on Amazon for example so that's
delivery drivers and we're making more
Journeys and there was lots of growth
there
ad revenues fell because of the global
economic crisis most of these companies
certainly the social media ones are very
reliant on Advertising to make no
profits and we also saw people no longer
working from home and we were very
reliant on their goods and services
while we were working at home some of
those factors contributed to it as well
as the sort of General economic Outlook
and they shrank significantly
um so it's a sort of business story
about the conglomerates and the way they
shrink and these things come and go but
there was something more interesting in
the big Tech slide as well and it was
it's not like the bubble has burst but
some people in Silicon Valley I've been
speaking to are saying the hype bubble
took you could almost hear that popping
you're gonna have to explain it to me
I'll give you a very good example
remember Facebook yes I do yes
they rebranded last year we were all
busy with a pandemic but they rebranded
themselves to meta
now you could argue cynically it was
partly to try and quickly change their
image given a lot of bad press around
some of the things that have been going
on revealed by whistleblowers Etc but it
was also because Mark Zuckerberg who
leads
the company formerly called Facebook now
meta he wanted to
illustrate his vision where he he
thought the world of big Tech was going
and it was going into the metaverse it
was we could leave the universe we
currently live in and we could meet each
other in this virtual world and they had
a vision for how they were going to do
it
and what we saw a year later was no
one's particularly impressed
have you tried it I have but I've been
inside now the technology when you put a
virtual reality headset on there is
there is some magic there like that and
I think we should they should we should
say this from the outset the metaverse
probably is going to be a wonderful
thing at some point in the future it's
just not happening as quickly as I think
some of these companies wanted us to
believe and expected their investors
also to believe look we cannot talk
about big Tech without mentioning the
kind of the biggest text audience
probably of the latter half of this year
after a somewhat protracted process Elon
Musk he of Tesla he of SpaceX you know
reached down the back of the sofa found
44 billion and decided to buy Twitter
how's that going not well is it and I
think this this also speaks to that sort
of hype bub a little bit more you know
Elon Musk is no no there is no doubt
he's a Visionary he has driven a vision
he has driven companies to succeed in
incredible ways but
the way he's communicated and handled to
take over Twitter I think that the mask
has slipped a little bit and we're
getting a little insight into some of
the the vanity and the
the let's face it rather odd values and
aspirations of some of these Titans of
big technology and that sort of
undermined a lot of people's confidence
and I'm not speaking for myself maybe to
arguably left-leaning journalistic sort
of you these are you know big investors
on Wall Street and people like that
aren't liking what they see and they're
nervous about it but who would have
thought that you know a kind of a tech
billionaire might be just a little bit
weird I mean just in terms of my own
experience on Twitter I I didn't really
notice much of a change but recently
certainly a number of spam accounts that
appear to be cropping up that has
increased the level of the invective
that is directed at certain people that
appears to have increased I mean like
Twitter was not known as a cash cow was
it it was not a massively profitable
Organization for most of its existence
so why did he go for it
the best analysis I've had is because he
loved it and when he sets his mind to
something and somebody challenges him he
will not be beaten so he'll go ahead but
he set himself a very difficult task of
making it profitable maybe it was never
going to work as a profit making
um app and in the current climate with
other platforms like Instagram and the
other social media apps they're not
performing particularly well either
because of AD revenues even the giant
that is Tick Tock in uh globally is is
having its own struggles of remaining
profitable so it's a difficult space to
be in and a lot of people are looking at
Elon Musk and saying you are you're a
Visionary for driving Engineers to solve
big problems but social media really
might not be your natural habitat and as
a broader point there is still this as
yet unresolved tension between on the
one hand people like Elon Musk describe
themselves as kind of freedom of speech
absolutist and the fact that in every
country that they work in there is a
jurisdiction there is a legal process
that they have to follow and indeed it's
something we're talking about very
openly in this country at the moment
absolutely you're seeing I mean there
are some people speculating that Twitter
may not even be able to continue to
operate in the EU on the rules will they
be able to operate under our Online
safety bill which I want to say a bit
more in a moment you know there are
suggestions that Tick Tock because of
the relationship with the US China may
be blocked in that country you know next
year is going to be a very very
interesting one to see how social media
platforms continues to operate as
Society catches up with just how awful
they are I think one of the things that
I'm most looking forward to in the year
to come will be our Online safety bill
in the UK it's a very complex piece of
legislation it's going to be hard fought
over but I think anybody but
particularly a parent and I have young
children seeing their interaction with
social media something has to change we
cannot continue as a society with the
relationship that young people currently
have with social media apps it's
something's really got to give there
it's a very dangerous world out there
Tom you draw birth for a second uh still
to come though we will be discussing
exactly where we are at with covid and
how Medical Science can continue to
improve our lives in 2023 and Beyond
there we are
[Music]
uh welcome back we did promise you on
the daily that we would be looking
positively into 2023 we'll do that in a
minute uh Tom Clark our Science and
Technology editor is still here um Tom
we cannot review the year in fact review
the past three years let's say uh
without mentioning covet and I suppose
the thing that for many people has has
been pretty pleasing is that yeah we're
back in Winter lots of people are having
you know the respiratory infections and
so on and so forth but but in terms of
covet it hasn't come back and made the
impact that some quite felt it would
yeah I think if you ask me this question
this time last year I would have told
you we still have a long way to run we
have no idea how this is going to pan
out we had new variants emerging we
didn't know how much of a threat they
were going to pose to people we had a
pretty awful winter Peak if you recall
and then on into the early months of
last year as well but what we've seen as
the the vaccines have been rolled out
and dare I say as more of us have been
infected possibly on top of having had
those vaccines that are the the impact
way he's been having has been much
milder and it's been shorter lived we do
have a winter coming up I'd hate to sort
of be too optimistic but I think we can
certainly be far more optimistic having
seen a couple of recent Autumn waves of
covid come around about this winter in
terms of covert transmission and and
illness in a hospital we could have been
before is that because of the vaccines
because I would have thought by no I
mean I'm I'm lucky really yeah good good
I I think I think the vaccines have
proven their worth and then some they
are not perfect very very few vaccines
are they do not stop the virus being
transmitted around
but what we've seen is the levels of
hospitalization the the the severity of
disease that people are having has just
got less and less and less and less that
has been a huge benefit of those
vaccines and possibly ugly the fact
they're not perfect the fact they're
still allowing the virus to transmit a
little bit might be helping although for
those people who are vulnerable this is
obviously not a good thing at all but
for the population at large allowing the
virus to move around a little bit it
continuous infect us that's happened to
my family a couple of weeks ago
um you know that is further sort of
boosting our immunity as we go forward
and when it comes to new and emerging
diseases I think there's already
evidence
the problem's only getting worse in
terms of threats and we need to go
beyond the lessons that we learned from
codeine I mean you've got monkey box and
pox as we're not supposed to call it my
last trip to Scotland the number of dead
gillenots I saw on the beach alerts me
to the van you know avian flu is still
an issue there is some stuff out that we
need to keep our eyes on yeah we have a
disease like Ebola which is exquisitely
deadly compared to covid that used to
cause very occasional intense but very
small outbreaks we've had increasingly
numbers of quite deadly
um Ebola outbreaks which thankfully the
most recent one does seem to be coming
under control but constant reminders of
the way with seven billion people on the
planet the need to feed them all with
agricultural methods that push
intensification you know bird flu is a
worrying example of a virus which in
recent years actually looks like it's
less of a threat to humans it is very
closely related to human flu viruses it
wouldn't take very much for it to you
know become a concern for human
transmission we certainly saw that
something like covid we cannot carry on
doing things the way we're doing when it
comes to agriculture the way we move
food around the planet the way we expect
to buy cheap food I mean there are lots
of concerns around that interface
between our biodiversity and diseases
and that's going to cause that should be
very very high on the agenda at the
moment I think Tom as you know I am a
man of my words and we did promise our
listeners some reasons to be cheerful
and and we got two of them this year
we've got quite a lot of them this year
but we've got two in particular on
malaria and on a topic you and I
discussed not long ago Alzheimer's
that's right I mean starting with
Alzheimer's a major breakthrough and I I
don't like using that word when it comes
to Science and Technology because that's
not really how science works it's a slog
not some you know great Eureka moment
after Eureka moment but we had one
recently with the discovery of a of the
first drug that slows the progression of
Alzheimer's disease it was modest in its
effects it very much a first go but it
it proves that science is on the right
track and I think it's going to really
open up the field of outsider's research
to More Money More drug development and
I think for the for the millions of
families out there living with with
Alzheimer's living with someone with
Alzheimer's it's a real cause for hope
on malaria we were talking there was a
lot of bad news in terms of diseases but
again a vaccine uh that was trialled
this uh this year showed 80 efficacy to
reduce the effects of Malaria that's a
potentially huge development if that
huge number of life saved yeah 650
000 kids a year died malaria is
estimated you know so the impact of That
vaccine could be enormous for for those
societies and for those families and and
and and uh yeah so you it's hard to
overestimate the impact of a good one
they're a vaccine and just two more
picks I want to throw in there we gave
big Tech an awfully hard time with this
podcast yeah and I think they bought it
upon themselves but look at what
artificial intelligence is doing yes it
does threaten to take over the world and
drive us all out of work and and there's
a dystopian future for artificial
intelligence but we saw some a
significant breakthrough this year in
using AI to understand disease and I
think applying computing power to human
biology is going to be a big story in
the coming year or two we'll see a lot
of discoveries there and
they couldn't be a bigger threat than
Global Annihilation we could be wiped
out by a comet at any minute but the
other great breakthrough this year NASA
their Dart Mission proved we can nudge
asteroids off course and potentially
save life on Earth and I think that what
what more to be cheerful about there is
than that brilliant stuff although I
will say at this juncture uh are you
famous the artificial intelligence that
can host this game use daily and I'll
give you 20 quid Tom Clark many thanks
indeed thanks for joining us on this
special edition of The Daily we of
course have covered in Greater depth a
lot of the topics that Tom and I have
been discussing on this this episode on
other episodes of The Sky News Daily
just do a search for those words right
there we'll see you again
[Music]
foreign